but now we're up to something which is
even crazier i think in my mind where do
you guys stand on 230 are the platforms
in your mind david
responsible for uh the new york times
publishing a story did you think they
should have blocked the new york times
story about hunter biden and the
post definitely not a new york times
star definitely not new york times
that would have been hilarious uh new
york post
like they would never have blocked the
new york times right i mean let's be
honest
well there's a i mean the crazy thing
here is like god this is such a can of
worms like
the i mean specifically answer your
question
i think no they shouldn't have for a
bunch of reasons but one of which just
simply being the streisand effect right
like
the there was a practical reason to not
do it yeah like the fact that streisand
effect being though what was it was that
barbra streisand's malibu mansion
had like coastal erosion going on and
she tried to hide the photo and prevent
it from being published and that just
made it more of a thing
like this just made a non-story a huge
story
yeah so that would be a a practical
reason not to do it if you were actually
trying to not put attention towards it
but then even if it was stolen material
and a publication that's been around as
the new york post but that is
right-leaning
should a platform then choose
to link to it or not well so now this is
great this is
we're getting into what jack's sort of
proposed solutions were
in the hearings um and and one of the
things
at least the sentiment that he echoed
and that mark zuckerberg echoed were
hey it would be great to have like clear
guidelines around what we're supposed to
do with 230 when you have objectionable
content
and objectionable can mean lots of
things but let's just zoom in on the
most obvious example like
um outright hate speech and you have
something that's either
you know um yeah like like the most
aggressive form of trolling
the the platforms today under some
circumstances take that down and no
one's sort of
arguing like well if they take that down
then
they voided 230 and now they're going to
be regulated as a media publication it's
like well they're taking down something
that's like the the filth of the
internet so like i'm glad that they're
thinking like but this is a thing that
they're taking into their own hands and
it's not laid out in 230 or anywhere
else like here's the types of things
that you should take down and here's the
types of things that
in order to remain neutral you should
leave up and so
the issue that we have right now is that
this 1996
you know law or small piece of a law
that uh allows the uh
parties to the facebooks and twitters
and
you know i'm not totally sure why sundar
was in there and we were
having a conversation about youtube in
the same
i i it makes sense but it didn't seem
like he was sort of on the same level as
the other two in the in the grilling
but um in order to
uh retain this status where 230 has this
carve out for us not to be responsible
for the content published on our
platform
it would be nice to update it and give
us some guidance on what we should and
should not take down
so i you know let's go to uh let's sort
of this clip here
of uh jack responding and i thought this
was a very interesting one
where he talks a little bit about the
algorithms and how the algorithm
algorithms are making an editorial
decision and that kind of breaks 230
and here is uh just 30 seconds of jack
and
we'll come back after this and a
commercial break for
some feedback and finally much of the
content people see today is determined
by algorithms
with very little visibility into how
they choose what they show
we took a first step in making this more
transparent by building a button to turn
off our home
timeline algorithms it's a good start
but we're inspired by the market
approach suggested by dr stephen wolfram
before this committee in june 2019
enabling people to choose algorithms
created by third parties to rank and
filter their content
is an incredibly energizing idea that's
in reach